hey everyone welcome back to a new
coffee break here on my channel firm
learning my name is heineken from
learning i want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career and today i want to talk about
how to build a personal brand how to
build an influence on linkedin i will
first talk about where you as a young
professional should do that and why
linkedin is the perfect platform for it
at this point in time i will second
spill the tea on how the linkedin
algorithm works to help you go viral i
will third give you some tangible tips
on profile optimization to become a
creator and last but not least i will
share some tips on how to build a
content strategy that will work towards
your goals but before i just want to
spend a couple of seconds talking about
why i'm actually justified to even talk
about this topic so for those of you who
don't know me i started my social
platform firm learning in early 2020
started mainly on youtube but then also
growing on other platforms such as
instagram and tik tok and linkedin for
sure has been a priority for me at the
moment i'm posting quite regularly about
three to five times per week and this
enabled me to grow quite rapidly over
the last months and i will teach you in
this video the very strategy that i use
and the insights that i collected on the
way while doing it so let's start by
talking about why might be a good idea
for yourself to build a personal brand
and an influence on linkedin and let's
first assume the position of someone who
is already a senior leader in an
organization maybe a c-level executive
working somewhere why might you be
interested in linkedin i think there are
three reasons for that first employee
recruiting so if an employee wants to
find a new job that person would likely
look up the firm on linkedin and of
course if you publish regular content
that will be very instrumental for
potential candidates decide whether your
firm is the firm to join or not second
is corporate communications i would
claim that for most companies out there
if their leadership would post on
linkedin compared to an internal
channels for instance a corporate
intranet likely they would be able to
reach more of their internal staff on
linkedin likely their posts would be
seen more so do think that linkedin is a
crucial tool for corporate communication
as well and then last but not least of
course also lead generation there are
lots of examples how people are able to
create customers attract business by
using linkedin in the right way this is
a significant opportunity and i will
teach you how you can do this today but
even if you're a young professional not
necessarily in such a leadership
position yet if you use linkedin you can
build your personal brand you can build
an influence and with that you have all
the benefits of being a creator the
benefits of being a creator in this day
and age have been well described
elsewhere let's just say that the
opportunities for yourself both in terms
of personal growth but also in terms of
financial or career opportunities are
very very significant so why should you
focus on linkedin if you want to build a
professional brand at the moment and
there are many things i could talk about
let me focus on reach for the purpose of
this video at the moment even if you are
still a small account you have the
opportunity to reach a significant
amount of people on linkedin and this
might change over the next years maybe
maybe not but at the moment that's for
sure the case and let's compare that to
another platform for instance facebook
so let's say you have a facebook profile
with 1 000 followers well if you release
a post without boosting it with ads
likely only a fraction of these
followers will see that let's just say
roughly five percent so for thousand
followers maybe your post on average
will get about 50 views just the
fraction of your audience this is very
different right now on linkedin if you
have 1000 followers you can expect that
your posts will be seen by 2 000 people
so you can expect that a multiple of
your followers will regularly see your
content and this is of course a very
great and significant opportunity and
only very few platforms at the moment
out there that will give you a
comparable reach let's not substantiate
this with some action numbers and for
that i prepared some data from my own
account heidi rocha that i also use for
my from learning work this was data
pulled until the end of the first half
of this year at that point in time i had
about 18 000 followers and if i just
took the median post of all the posts
that i created the median post got about
30 000 views which is roughly two times
the followers that i had at that time
but there was also posts that received
188
000 views at that point in time so this
is 10x the followers that i had so this
illustrates the opportunities that are
out there and i will talk more about how
to write exactly these types of posts in
a moment the second question that i
often get is whether i should post on my
company page if you have one or on your
personal profile well if you're just an
individual chances are you only have
your personal profile available anyways
but the good news is that linkedin
favors personal profiles over company
pages when it comes to reach and of
course the reasons for that are i'd say
rather obvious of course linkedin would
love that the companies rather pay ads
pay ad money to boost their posts
whereas that's not that much of an
option for personal individuals but here
just as an example in the case of
volkswagen so volkswagen are gay the
company volkswagen has about 1.2 million
followers and you just picked a post of
them they just got a couple of hundred
likes and if you contrast that to her
but these who under recently elise was
the managing director of volkswagen even
though he had less than 300 000 views
his posts regularly get over a thousand
likes and of course there's some
variants among these polls but this is
the general picture that you see almost
everywhere personal profiles definitely
get more reach than company profiles on
linkedin so i definitely would encourage
you to use your personal profile as well
and last but not least it seems very
clear to me that the development of
linkedin into an influencer and creator
platform is a key strategic objective of
linkedin they're actively pushing it you
can see it with all the initiatives that
the company is coming up with for
instance the top voices award that now
they award on a yearly basis if you ever
felt like you wanted to build an
influence on instagram on youtube or any
of these other platforms but you were
just too late now is your opportunity
with linkedin because if you start now
you will definitely be still early in
the development of linkedin as a creator
platform the opportunities are out there
you just need to grab them so let's next
talk about the linkedin algorithm and
why should you even care about how the
linkedin algorithm works but then here
again i just looked at some of my own
personal data on my hindi user profile
this is again the data from the first
half year of this year and i just
ordered all the posts by the views that
they received and you can see that
there's quite a significant variance on
the left hand side there are some posts
that got less than 10 000 views again
let me remind you i had about 18 000
followers at that point in time but then
on the right hand side i had a handful
of posts that exceeded 100 000 views and
my most successful post measured in
views received as i just also told you
earlier about
188 000 views and of course views
matters because if people don't see your
content you cannot really spread the
messages that you want to spread you
cannot really work towards the goals and
objectives that you set for yourself in
the beginning and of course if people
don't find your polls they also cannot
find your profile and therefore you also
cannot grow your follower base and your
audience so let's look at how the
linkedin algorithm works behind the
scenes and this is very similar to
almost all the other social media
platform algorithms work this way and i
can imagine this to work is that at the
beginning if you post something linkedin
in the first minutes hours and so on
will show this post to a fraction of
your audience to a fraction of your
followers or to a fraction of the people
who usually enjoy the content that you
create and then they observe what
happens are these people spending time
on the post are they engaging with the
post are they leaving a comment so they
have all these types of indicators that
let the algorithm come to the conclusion
whether this is a good post or not and
so if this post performed well in this
very close group of your most engaged
followers then linkedin will likely show
this post to an extended group of your
followers to almost every one of your
followers and we'll look again how is it
performing is this performing well or
not and again if even with this extended
group linkedin comes to the conclusion
that yes it's a good post then likely it
will show this post to even more people
often also not even your followers
anymore but maybe people who linked them
believes to have similar interests than
the people who follow you people who are
similar to your followers and then again
a regard interest are they interested
are they engaging are they enjoying the
post and then based on that step by step
linkedin will show the post to even more
people up until the point where linkedin
just doesn't find any pockets of people
anymore where the linkedin algorithm
would be confident that these people
would enjoy your post as well and of
course sometimes there are these unicorn
posts where the algorithm comes to the
conclusion that actually more or less
everyone would enjoy it more or less
everyone likes it and then sometimes you
have these super viral posts that are
seen by hundred thousands if not
millions of people it's of course very
difficult to predict to write something
like this but occasionally this might
happen to you so what exactly are these
signals that the algorithm takes into
consideration and what's here important
for me to say is though that i don't
have any inside knowledge behind the
scene knowledge of how the algorithm
works the algorithm is first of all
secret and second it constantly changes
what these are are just some common
assumptions where people test the things
and this is what you will find on many
places on the internet that this is how
it works but it's definitely fair for
yourself to run your own experiment to
see what really benefits your specific
account so let's talk about some
positive signals first one of the most
important things is time on post one of
the key metrics that all these platforms
are optimizing is to keep people keep
users on the platform for as long as
possible because of course the longer
people spend on the platform the more
ads can be shown to these people and
this is usually one of the biggest
monetization levels that the platforms
have so time on post is key but then of
course sharing a post is a positive way
because if you share a post to your
network you're saying that hey this
pause is great it's important it's worth
seeing and worth reading next commenting
so linkedin wants to build a platform
where people engage with each other have
conversations about topics and comments
definitely work towards this goal it's a
key metric of engagement next sending a
post you can send the post to other
users to other people this is a positive
sign of course as well because thereby
you indicate that it's worth sending and
sharing of course if people follow your
profile after they read your post this
speaks towards the post as well and of
course liking a post also liking other
comments will increase engagement in the
same way and then of course they're
negative signals as well so of course
the big negative signals already of
these positive signals don't exist
aren't out there but then surely if
people hide the post so tell the
platform that they don't want to see
content like this this is very negative
if they unfollow you after they read
something from you if they mute the post
from you also if they report the post
that you created these are of course
negative signals from the algorithm and
if so far you received any value from
this video please hit the like button
for the algorithm and also follow or
subscribe to stay up to date on all my
content i will talk more about this
going forward so would love you to stay
on board here next let's talk about some
little tips what you can do to improve
your profile especially with the goal of
becoming a creator and first of all i
would encourage you to use a background
picture many profiles still don't use
background pictures but if someone
visits your profile the first time for
instance after having seen a post in the
feed the background picture is what
really gives your profile character and
you can use it to directly brand
yourself make sure that the key messages
are transported make sure that people
directly understand what you are all
about what they can expect if they
follow you next is the tag line so the
tagline is the line that is displayed
below your name the tagline is very
important because it's shown across many
places on the platform so usually
whenever you write a post below your
name there will also be the tagline
present so this gives the first
impression what is your background what
are you all about why should people be
interested in yourself so make it as
concise and as punchy as possible and
avoid using too many words next are
hashtags so if you turn on the crater
mode i will show you what this is in a
moment you have the opportunity to add
hashtags like this on your profile this
again helps the algorithm to understand
what the niches that you're talking
about what topics you are focusing on
this is also called your authority and
will also help the linkedin search to
place you in the appropriate search
results for this last but not least make
use of the future section so linkedin
provides you with a section where you
can hand select certain posts that you
feel like very well represent what's
going on on your page what you're doing
what you're writing about the signature
pieces of content that you created in
the past make use of that because again
this is the ideal place to give the
first impression to people who are new
to your personal brand or new to your
profile to understand what you're all
about let's now also talk about the
creator mode on your profile you should
find the option to turn on the creator
mode this will give you access to some
additional features that are very
relevant to creators so i would
definitely recommend you to do that for
instance you have access to these
hashtags that i showed you a moment ago
and another thing that automatically
happens if you turn on the creator mode
is that the main call to action on your
profile changes from connect to follow
so usually on standard profiles people
see the connect button so people can
connect with the person but then of
course the other person needs to accept
this connection request this way follow
means that the people want to see your
content want to see your posts but the
other person doesn't need to approve
that so the hurdles are lower people are
not afraid that maybe you won't accept
them so if you change the call to action
to follow this will enable and encourage
more people to follow you and therefore
for you to grow your audience of course
people can still connect with you but
this will not be the main call to action
displayed on your profile anymore let's
now talk about the content strategy and
in this section i want to talk about
some tips some advice some little
tactics and hacks that you can use to
really create the best possible content
for the platform and maximize your
chances to eventually create some
content pieces that will also go viral
and thereby blow up your account what's
important in the very beginning is that
you should think about a niche a topic
that you want to stand for so if people
think about you what do they want to
have in mind what are the key topics
that you want to associate yourself with
so this is called your niche and this
should be rather specific you don't
necessarily from the very first day you
need to have a very tangible first niche
in mind i think it's also fair just to
start with more generic content and then
over time converge towards a niche but
in the medium term you should develop
this for yourself because think about it
if you follow someone why are you
following a profile because you want to
read more of this type of content but if
the content of a person's all over the
place changes all the time
why should someone follow you so think
about your niche first and then from
your niche you can then derive the
content pieces that you want to create
and let's now start by talking about the
anatomy of a successful post on linkedin
and let's start with the hook the post
should always start with a hook so these
are often one or two sentences that just
spark interest create interest let
people want to read more about the post
let's remember the time on post is one
of the most important indicators for the
linkedin algorithm so you want to excite
people you want to motivate people to
read all the posts because this is what
will get you time on post after the hook
there's the body and in this body in the
main part of your post you should always
focus on communicating value on
communicating some insights things that
other people can take away can learn
from what you're writing about this is
at least the rule of thumb you might
occasionally deviate from that but the
majority of your posts should be based
on this framework what many people do
wrong is that they write posts
completely self-centered just about
themselves about their business all the
great things that they did in the past
that's boring people don't want to read
them make it about the value that you
can deliver to the other person next
around the end of the post end with a
call to action so ask people to do
something here's also fair to vary these
call to actions over time maybe
encourage people to leave a comment
because this of course sparks engagement
or you can encourage people to follow
your page if they want to read more
about this specific type of content
right so leave a call to action
encourage people to do something because
again this will also favor you in the
algorithm now i don't want to talk about
hashtags too much here in this video i
trust you're all familiar with them from
other platforms the last thing that i
want to talk about is that it's quite
striking that at least at the moment in
the linkedin algorithm posts that have
an attachment so some type of picture
for instance or a slideshow video
anything like that they tend to perform
significantly better in the linkedin
algorithm so i just looked at my top 10
best performing posts and eight of these
top 10 best performing posts had some
type of picture attached to them so in
general i would recommend you to always
use a picture if you struggle to come up
with a picture that really meets the
message of the post what many people do
is just include a random picture of
themselves and they just attach such a
picture of themselves to the post i
tried this out myself and i can just
only say it works it significantly
improves the reach of your content so
let's now deep dive on the hook so on
the first sentences that you leave on
your post here what you need to
understand that after a couple of lines
there is the so called fold so linkedin
only shows the beginning of the post and
after a couple of lines then it just
says see more and people need to click
on see more to see the remainder of the
post so here what's important is that
you're able to place the full hook
before the fold make sure the full hook
is seen before then this fold arrives
and the good thing is that where this
fold is placed is predictable and it
depends on whether there is an
attachment to the post or not and if you
follow the recommendation that i just
gave you a moment ago you will almost
always have such an attachment attached
to the post and if this is the case then
this fold appears after three lines of
content so you see this here in the left
example three lines and then the fold
appears and if there's no attachment
this fold appears after five lines so
here in the example to the right you see
four lines of text but then there's also
an empty line an empty line this counts
as way so after five lines then there
will be the fold so of course with your
hook you want to encourage people to
click on see more so maybe you are
ending with a question in the hook that
then you are answering in the remainder
of the post or maybe you make a rather
controversial statement then you explain
in the remainder of the post so
encourage people to click on see more
because of course just the fact alone
the people click on see more is in
itself already a positive sign to the
algorithm that people find this most
interesting and they want to learn more
about it let's not talk about another
little hack that you can do in your
content strategy to boost the reach of
your posts and this is occasionally
creating posts that really focus on
boosting engagement focus on getting as
much engagement as possible and one type
of post that is very suited to do that
are surveys see in this example you can
see that i created a survey it got about
40 000 impressions of 40 000 views and
there were about 2 000 people who
participated in the survey who clicked
on an option in the survey so two
thousand people is quite a lot for a
post of myself so you can often see that
service get quite a lot of engagement
like this and the good thing is if a
person interacted with your content in
this way even though this person did not
necessarily follow you then this person
is more likely to in the future see
posts that you created that you wrote
because linkedin now thinks that hey
this person might be interested in your
content so i would not encourage you to
always only create posts like this
because the truth is also only because
someone participated in the survey
doesn't necessarily mean that that
person is really interested in your
content doesn't necessarily mean that
now the person will go to your profile
and follow you but occasional posts like
this can help to increase your
engagement increase your views in the
medium term just one word of caution in
the past also earlier this year linkedin
was quite swamped with posts where
people were doing surveys not with the
survey 2 which i think is also rather
new on linkedin but rather by abusing
the different types of like buttons they
could participate in the server by
clicking the like button or the
insightful like button or the love like
button and so on and using that as a
survey and by that of course getting
lots of engagement so recently i've not
really seen any of these types of posts
anymore on my timeline so i think here
this is an example of how linkedin
adjusted the algorithm to not punish
these types of posts which is why at the
moment i would not recommend you to
create this type of content so let's not
talk about another strategy for your
content and this is the built-in public
strategy maybe you've already heard
about it there was quite a lot of buzz
around it and the main idea is this is
especially suitable for maybe
entrepreneurs so anyone in leadership
position that you just talk about what
you're building about the company the
organization that you're building and
just regularly share some insights on
that maybe once per week you share your
biggest learnings of the last week or
the biggest achievements what you learn
from them maybe also some failures what
you learn from that so this is just a
strategy where you can really lift the
curtains let people in into your
business and provide value down the road
this can of course help to create trust
with potential employees with potential
customers this is a great strategy to
create new leads i'm just showing you
here an example of a gentleman so for
full disclosure i don't know this
gentleman i also don't want to endorse
any of his content or his activities i
just thought this was a nice example of
where someone is doing exactly that
there are many other examples out there
so let's now talk about some typical
mistakes that many people are doing and
here i'm now referencing this book from
the great gary vaynerchuk jab jab jab
right hook maybe some of you have seen
it and the big notion of this book is
that if you want to be successful in
social media in the world out there
rather focus on the jabs and be rather
measured in your use of right hooks and
in this picture the jab is a piece of
content a post that focuses on
delivering value for the audience
whereas the right hook is the message
where you have some type of commercial
interest maybe you want someone to
become a customer of yourself and as the
title already says jab jab jab right
hook right so for every right hook for
every commercial message make sure that
there's a good number of really value
creating messages before that or to say
differently your profile should not look
like a big advertisement this is frankly
what i sometimes see people also do
wrong with this built-in public strategy
where they just talk about how great
their organizations are great their
company is this is not what people want
to read all the time in your content
focus on delivering value for others and
if you do that consistently then people
will very much understand if you
occasionally also place this right hook
with your own commercial interest let's
now talk about sharing other posts and
in principle there's nothing wrong with
that you just need to be aware that how
the system the algorithm works is that
if you share another post that mainly
helps the reach of the other posts so
the other posts will often be shown to
more people potentially also to more
people in your audience so the post that
you yourself create by sharing another
post potentially also with some comments
this post in itself will often only get
a fraction of the views than such a post
would usually get so sharing other posts
is great for the post that you're
sharing but often doesn't help you if
you want to create a post yourself that
gets lots of reach lots of views so
depending on your goals you might still
want to share the other post to support
it or you just decide to create a new
post by yourself that picks up some of
the main messages and then has higher
chances to get the reach let's now also
talk about linking external resources
for instance adding a link to another
website to your post and here the truth
is also that this is very bad for the
reach of your posts i've recently seen
an analysis of another person with a
conclusion the post with external links
receive on average only one sixth of the
reach of a post without external links
and the reason for that i think is also
quite obvious of course linkedin likes
to keep people on the platform linkedin
doesn't like to leave people from the
platform which is why they are punishing
posts that have these external links so
my advice would be that if you do want
to link to an external page don't put
the link in the original post but rather
put the link in the comments and then
you can write on the post something like
okay link to the page in the comments
and this will then to some extent bypass
this reach penalty that linkedin
otherwise would put on your post but now
i would love to hear from you do you
have any other linkedin strategies and
tips to share leave a comment here in
the comment section i'd love to get all
your insights and learn from you as well
again if you enjoyed it or took any
value from it please hit the like button
for the algorithm and also subscribe and
follow to stay up to date on all the
content big big thanks to the members of
from learning as well thank you for your
support my name is heinrich i'm the
creator from learning talk to you again
soon